el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski se presentó ante el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas a
través de una videoconferencia allí
detalló los supuestos crímenes de guerra
cometidos por rusia en ucrania y pidió
que los perpetradores sean llevados a un
tribunal internacional
y las tropas rusas mataron a cualquier
persona que haya servido a nuestro país
y han matado mujeres afuera de su casa
cuando simplemente trataban de llamar a
mataron familias enteras adultos niños
trataron de quemar los cuerpos
al mismo tiempo criticó la falta de
contundencia del organismo pidió
eliminar a rusia del consejo de
seguridad e incluso planteó su
disolución se ve incapaz de resolver el
conflicto de su parte el secretario
general de la onu antonio guterres habló
del compromiso del organismo para
esclarecer las denuncias de crímenes de
guerra de una bestia que nunca olvidaré
las horribles imágenes de civiles
asesinados y maritza inmediatamente de
una investigación independiente
destinada a defender el principio de
responsabilidad pero el embajador ruso
ante la onu negó las acusaciones y
rechazó la versión sobre las
evacuaciones
a su país asegurando que 600 mil
personas han entrado a su territorio sin
ningún tipo de coerción y más de 119.000
son niños también reiteró la perspectiva
rusa del conflicto
vinimos a ustedes a ucrania no para
conquistar tierras vinimos a traer la
tan esperada paz a la tierra empapada de
sangre del donbass no una tregua sino
una verdadera paz duradera y para esto
tenemos que erradicar la crueldad que ya
he mencionado
necesitamos extirpar el tumor maligno
nazi que está consumiendo a gran ya y
que con el tiempo comenzaría a klum y la
rusia
es precisamente en el tumbas donde la
otan asegura que rusia realizará una
nueva